[Music]
joining us now with reaction or opening
monologue to women who did accused
President Bill Clinton of sexual
misconduct and being a predator Paula
Jones money to broader good to see both
it's great to have you have a new book
that has come out I actually have a copy
of it here because you forgot to bring
me I have an autograph okay you better
put some ice on that how I survived
being raped by Bill Clinton yeah now
what's amazing about this is have you
ever been interviewed on 60 minutes
oh no never they are seeing in our MSNBC
yeah well there it is yeah you've never
been interviewed by CNN now MSNBC 60
minutes never and it was hard to get it
on NBC with Lisa Myers who I know wanted
to air her interview with you yes and I
have said this to you in all my years
I'm now 23 years of Fox 30 years in
radio your interview and you actually
write about some of this in the book was
the hardest interview I have ever done
oh that's right you know I and you were
the second interview that I had done and
the last of course there was a Dorothy
Rabinowitz in between but when you came
to my home with all of your people and
sit down I never thought about this
being as emotional to you as it you know
as it was to me but we sat down and as I
began to tell you the horrific events
this is a brutal rape yes when I began
to tell you about that I turned and
looked at you at one time
and he had tears in his eyes and it just
it almost just it just overwhelmed me
you've always been so good to us and I
appreciate it you know one thing that
Lisa Myers said to you when she said we
can't air the interview right now she
said well I have two good news and bad
news you're credible yeah you're two
credible right and this whole title you
better put some ice on that is from the
story what he raped you and when he was
done and he told you because he had bit
your lip yes he bit my lip to keep me
quiet but the time he hit was leaving
the room
calmly puts on his sunglasses and
motions to my lip
and says you better put some ice on that
and coldly walks out the door you had
the experience and you you won your
lawsuit I did you got a judgment in your
favor they settle this if you ask the
Liberals though no absolutely not okay
you won a lot of money too okay and but
he exposed himself he guest noticed you
invited you to the hotel room mm-hmm
and he dropped his pants exactly here's
my question you watch the interview with
stormy right yes I did okay and you see
the breathless history of the coverage
this is yeah insane when you compare one
ITA's story your story Kathleen Willey
was not here for comparison hey you know
that you know what mr. Trump if he did
that you know what it wasn't a crime he
didn't he did not do something that was
a crime there's a difference there she
admitted that he didn't do anything to
her that hurt her whatever you know he
she was a willing participant and it's
so different but we did not get the same
kind of coverage that she's getting
maybe aegis absolutely we were made fun
of we were talked about we were on
late-night talk shows you know making
fun of of us you know
yeah remember James Carville you know
dragged a hundred-dollar bill through a
prime dollar bill to a trailer park yes
absolutely I've never lived in trailer
park but you know I mean that's the way
they treated us and this was a serious
thing and you know that even through
Hillary's election she never ever was
asked anything about us women never
usually when she said Oh women have a
right to be heard yes and to believed
and having interviewed both of you and
Kathleen in the past I remember saying
that does that mean we believe 1e2 no
not after I tweeted what I did on
January the 6th she calmly removed you
should be believed from her website
interesting yeah you tweeted last night
at Anderson Cooper in 60 minutes I did
and you tweeted Oh would you like to
interview me about my book yeah yeah you
heard from Anderson yet you ever got on
with Anderson but I'm not a porn star I
was a hard work
you know nurse uh you know I was and and
I was a hardworking person but I wasn't
a porn star so I guess that's why they
weren't interested in me i I think it
was because of politics and the idea is
I've always talked about this president
having five big groups against them
you got the deep state we talk about
that a lot you got the liberal media you
got Democrats Republicans and never
Trump us it seems like if you're a
Democrat me - doesn't matter it seems if
you're a Democrat women's rights don't
matter in Utah are living examples of it
I know I know it's just like when they
contacted me to do an interview for the
me - long before we knew they were going
to be Person of the Year I told him I
did not feel a part of that because no
one had ever included me in it this was
and I sure I'd alter from time you were
me - long before the me - for it I know
and then they asked me to submit a
comment to them which I said okay I will
in support of the me - and then all of a
sudden they come out as being Person of
the Year and I look for my comment and
it wasn't there Wow yeah me too
before what do you say to all of those
people that act so sanctimonious and so
they're feigning such outrage over -
alleged consensual relationship well you
know it's because they're trying to get
Donald Trump out of office they're going
to do everything they can that is my
opinion that they're gonna do everything
they can to try and impeach him or you
know try to drag up stuff about what
it's now about though is it about now we
want every detail of every consensual
relationship going back dozen years of
it only if it's a Republican I'm not a
Democrat lately ya know it's not about
was it hard seeing all this and then
does it bring up memories for both of
you of what you are whatever yeah it
never goes away I tweeted that one time
you know back in 2016 it's something
it's it's like Leslie Mill we said today
when you've been victimized as horrific
ly as I was it's in your DNA
you do not forget it all right I want to
thank you good to see you both the way
Paul's started a coffee company that
swear is not gonna lose weight so she
gave us some coffee
thank you this book by the way you can
get it on amazon.com Hannity calm and I
guess in bookstores amazon.com Noble
what is it Barnes & Noble can I tell my
website oh sure
it's Paula's weight loss coffee dot-com
okay and you can contact me on Facebook
Paula Jones thank you both good to see
Thank You Sean